foreign
I was afraid people in my group would
um say bad stuff about my prototype and
they asked us to like cut people took a
while to understand the concept
this program that we have worked with
the students of family Methodist
secondary school for five weeks it's
about trying to help them unleash their
creativity and be able to think
differently through a variety of
ideation experience and also thinking
through making as well one of the pain
of project work coursework whatever in
secondary school level is the validation
of one right answer and then internally
to criticize their idea and throw away
all the possibility refuse to take the
next step until they get it right so
they can get started for weeks I think
it's something that we need to win them
off
quite unconventional right how they how
they taught us to design things
stretch the students thinking to become
more out of the box
um
during this program I heard it a lot of
times is it like you think
and then you think it's a good
combination word between the word think
and Tinker it's a process of ideation
exploration experimentation after that
making observations and deductions there
are a few mindsets that we also
encourage the students to adopt I
enjoyed the part where I had to do first
and think later there's also another one
it's um quantity over quality I think so
we don't uh
like One Singular idea we want to break
them out of this small and also by not
limiting themselves by the spirit of
exploration and experimentation before
this I actually didn't know like any
like ways to like be creative open it
and just all the robotic grammar
[Music]
go beyond that comfort zone discover
something they may not know and this
will be the gems of innovation and
creativity in the design process they
are learning what the real world is
actually using when they're trying to
solve Solutions uh come up with
solutions by virtue of them having
interactions with the professionals it
enhances their own thinking skills their
thinking capacity
collectible and you're able to kind of
put it into your laptop sleeve
a six week process it is already a
remarkable achievement for them to get
out of this mindset anything really over
the weeks being more and more students
they are engaged in the making they make
first and then they look at what they do
and then get inspiration from Rick and
iterate from there now I think I'm like
it's opened up like a lot of
possibilities
[Music]
made me feel more creative and I'm more
confident yeah it was quite exciting
because things you do are the same so
it's nice to have something different to
what we usually do
everybody can be creative it's just like
whether you put your mind to it or not
foreign